[Music]
welcome back everybody to the t3m
podcast
i'm your host rami musla alongside with
my co-host
fayad and angel how are you guys doing
today
take that as
what are we talking about boys so in the
beginning of the first episode we talked
about why god
very briefly very briefly talk about why
god then we talked about
okay god exists why islam first we talk
about why not christianity
kind of threw under the bus then we
talked about why islam
so now we have a lot of people
that may be falling into cognitive
dissonance
i'm sure you guys are familiar with the
term but for those of you who don't know
one example of cognitive dissonance
would be
two conflicting ideas that are in a
person's head they do not how to
they don't know how to resolve these two
conflicting ideas
and they trigger a fight-or-flight
reaction which turns into anxiety or
depression or anger frustration which is
why you've seen debates or arguments
especially religious ones or ones that
are focused on your worldview
including atheists when you talk about
darwinism which has become more of a
religion now
they get really anxious and they get
really angered and they start insulting
this is
due to cognitive dissonance because they
don't know how to deal with it so
throughout this episode you find
yourself getting angry
even though we're not being
disrespectful or rude or intolerant or
insulting
you might find that you feel as
if we are and this is because of
cognitive dissonance because
a lot of people and we talked about in
the first episode how people
they grew up in a very specific way and
we're basically a product of our
surroundings
and we adopt the views the politically
correct views
of the society in which we grow up in
which is a big issue
to deem these as correct because there
would be people on the
same earth as you at the same time in a
different location
that will also grow up on their
politically correct views
like the ugandan movement
with the why are you gay guy
his kids will grow up thinking
homosexuality is
an absurdity and it is an outrage and it
is definitely wrong
morally but we will in the west people
say
it is politically correct and not just
that it is actually morally okay and so
on and so forth
so how do you reconcile these two
different views of life nobody can say
oh i'm right
because nope not everybody can be right
and morals is something that you can't
necessarily prove unless you believe in
objective morality
so other people will disagree on
fundamental views that they have
with other people who will disagree on
fundamental views that they have
so now everybody can be right so amongst
these views
like i mentioned homosexuality is the
view that all religions
the three abrahamic religions are
homophobic because they disagree with
homosexuality
on a moral standpoint islam specifically
and you guys know that i talked to jc
about this on my live and i had a few
back and forth videos with him on tik
tok about this
because he was painting islam to be this
horrible religion that is homophobic and
so on and so forth
but upon further investigation we came
to the conclusion that it as a fact it's
not
and many people might not might not know
this but actually western views
western views is what is intolerant or
previous western reviews is what was
intolerant
towards homosexuality in a i would say
in the vile manner that it's been
presented in
in the past so people adopt this
view on homosexuality in the west
deeming it to be okay and so on and so
forth
simply because it's political
politically correct and this is what
they were brought up on
there is actually most of the time no
scientific grounds
for this belief it is just let people be
and it's this liberalistic idea but we
know the problem with liberalism is not
everybody can be ultimately free
because that means you can do whatever
you want we live in a society where you
can't do
whatever you want there are restrictions
there are
legal responsibilities and obligations
so where did this
political movement really start making
the impact that it's been making
in the west fired if you want to touch
on the subject no homo
inshallah let me touch it right now so
guys before we go in i just want to
commend
my bro rami wonderful introduction
wonderful trigger warning
ladies and gentlemen let's go into this
so for those of you that do not know
the apa or the american psychiatric
association
is the regulatory governing body in the
states
quickly affiliated with the world health
organization as well these are
like these are the people that set the
gold standards for mental
illness psychiatric illness
psychological disorders
these are the people that you go to they
created this book called the diagnostic
and statistical manual of mental
disorder called the dsm it's had a
couple of different modifications and
edits and
versions but from its inception until
1973
the diagnostic and statistical manual
the dsm
categorized sexual deviance including
homosexuality
pedophilic disorder transgenderism as
mental illness and dis-ease i just want
to
let you guys know something up front too
um
i'm gonna get angel because he explains
it well what do we mean when we say
disease
and when we keep saying it in this talk
are we trying to be demeaning
or what do we mean by that
so when you think about this ease
i got this from a assad guru video that
i saw
years ago where he basically said like
you break up the word so now you have
this ease
if you are in this ease then you're not
at ease
am i right like you're not good you're
not happy you're not
at ease you know enjoying your life the
way that you should be
and that is what a dis ease is now is
there
more medical terminology on it yeah is
it more
psychological terminology on it yeah but
in the most simplest terminology
if you are in deceased you're not at
ease you got something wrong you got
something affecting
your general state of being 100
man um good stuff that's that he
explained it perfectly guys
we're not trying to be demeaning we're
not trying to say disease like they're
sick and they're
they're messed up in the head we're not
not saying that
but that's the beauty of this talk we're
gonna really go into both sides what we
are saying though
is the dsm not me not rami not islam not
christianity the dsm gold standard
of mental disorder categorized sexual
deviance all of these different
umbrella terms that we talked about
homosexuality pedophilia
um gender dysphoria all of that as
mental illness
the apa's nomenclature task force was
forced
by the people to remove pedophilia
not pedophilia homosexuality and
transgenderism
from sexual deviance in 1973.
this was not due to any medical
advancement
any like technological scientific
revolution any
science that proved that it should be
removed but purely due
to peaceful protests and i say that
lightly because oftentimes they weren't
so peaceful
and they were kind of coerced by
political agendas and propaganda
to remove it they have then further
pushed for the removal of pedophilic
disorder
from the dsm but that has not been
successful as of yet might change
the times we live in um furthermore i
just want to let you know that they
created three
fake terms i say fake take it with a
grain of salt the first one is
homophobic
phobia which is a mental illness
categorized by
an abnormal fear or anxiety persistently
related to some symptom or some stimulus
which isn't true because if you and i go
outside
and we look at a gay guy and we get
scared okay that's by definition
homophobic
phobia but what they do is they created
this political term
to coin and coerce those that disagree
with the promotion of the lgbt agenda
not those that are actually
against or scared of homosexuals
bisexuals
lesbians trans so on and so forth they
then
coined the term um partner which
i don't really have a problem with they
just really hated the man and wife
man and woman wife husband or spouse
they really want to use partners so it
gives them the sense of inclusion
all of these things that sound in
hindsight very inclusive right they want
to put for
gender equality you know equal this it
sounds good
on the surface but it kind of changes
tone when you get a little deeper
they then talk about gender identity and
pronouns
i got no problem with but there's no
scientific basis if you're biologically
a he
um but again you wanna be called
a she i don't really see why i gotta
call you a she just to like make you
feel better
there's no scientific foundation for it
we're gonna talk about that um
and yeah so what i want to start with is
i know i got a quick question for you
you got
a gay you're not gay all right cool
question number two this guy this guy's
also a mind reader not only does he know
martial arts
uh this guy come on guys he's single too
i was gonna ask you question number two
insha allah so you got two healthy arms
bro
right you like your arms love them
you love your arms from from your i
guess genesis
of unhealth to age whatever we're not
going to disclose that right now
but you're in your mid 40s in your in
your four decades
of life i'm kidding guys he's not 40. um
have you ever felt like you have a
problem with your arms that they
shouldn't be there that
you want to get them removed
let's say let's say rami's a doctor rami
is the specialist he is a psychiatrist
he is a
uh brain surgeon he he deals with
everything with the psyche and
neuroscience you go to him and you're
like hey doctor
i don't like my arm i think i got to
remove it i just don't feel like it
should be a part of me
romney looks at it and says hey bro it's
a it's a perfectly healthy arm there's
nothing wrong with it
there's no there's no maladaptive
function there's no
i guess this ease there's no pathology
there's no
um abnormal function why do you want to
remove
and you're just out here saying i just
don't feel like it should be there
plain and simple i don't know if you
guys know where i'm going with this but
the problem with modern patients and
those that are
promoting the lgbt movement is they're
not trying to become
the top dog in modern medicine they're
not though
only modern medicine is the leader and
the innovator of medicine you as a
patient you can't go to a doctor
and try to promote your idea of what the
diagnosis should be
your job as a patient is only to say
these are my symptoms
the doctor comes and says okay this is
your diagnosis
modern medicines turn from what it used
to be as treating this disease and
disorders
um to becoming something that just makes
you feel better and treats these bad
feelings that you might have which isn't
really backed by any
evidence right so
let's talk about this first and foremost
john hopkins
medical school university hospital right
came up with a study
kind of groundbreaking but kind of not
because there's so many studies done on
this that support this idea
that the suicide rate of trans surgery
right post-op is astronomically higher
than the suicide rate pre-op what do i
mean by that
i mean the group of people that decide
they want to go
through transition surgery sex change
all of that
are 20 times more likely of committing
suicide
than those that didn't transition so you
really think about it they're promoting
this idea of okay you want to become a
guy
and you were born a girl or you want to
become a girl you were born a guy uh
with something between your legs cool we
can amputate that just like that arm
because you feel like that cool it'll
make you happy
but that's not what the research is
really showing
matter of fact um and i quote uh
you see dr mchugh who's the who's the
research
um you know the leader of the study said
that sex reassignment doesn't work it's
impossible
to reassign someone's sex physically and
attempting to do so doesn't produce good
outcomes at all
psychosocially so you guys have anything
to say about that what are your thoughts
about the suicide rates postdoc versus
pre-op
did you guys know about that is it
something that sits right with you
so initially when he mentioned that
a person goes to the doctor with their
symptoms and says this is what
i'm experiencing and the doctor gives a
diagnosis
i would say there's actually an issue on
that end of the spectrum as well because
we have a lot of doctors who are
prematurely
diagnosing young children and young
people
with um what i would call transsexuality
which means they're basically instead of
gender
instead of just gender dysphoria they're
actually saying okay this is the boy who
wants to be a girl
let's make them a girl and this is at a
point where they're not ready to make
this decision
and they make the decision and some of
them later regret it
but as a man and men will know this you
only have
the genitalia that you have so upon
removal of this genitalia it is too late
to put it back so if a person
is misdiagnosed by a professional
and the later regrets it this is going
to lead
to very very
to a very depressive state in which a
person may want to
or no longer want to live anymore and
this is the issue with gender dysphoria
and how it's viewed even from some
medical perspectives
because when you implement political
correctness
into the medical world you get this mess
of okay because i saw this picture and i
think it's funny it's a little cartoon
it was basically
a kid goes to the mom and they're like
mom i'm a dinosaur
and then mom's ignoring the kid and then
the next slide is
mom i'm i'm a police officer or
something like that and mom's ignoring
the kid
and then one day the boy because there's
a boy he goes with the mom the same kid
same mom he says mom i'm a princess and
she's like
you're a girl let's get you surgery
and then the doctor's like hey timmy
it's time to
and this is actually one thing i just
got to quickly know bro
first thing hashtag about american if
you know you know
yeah i was about to put it on right now
for everyone to see it there you go
and number two i really wanted to say
this right now
everything you know that's it right
there
bro makes sense take a look at the the
picture guys for a visual depiction of
what this man was spitting which was
facts but
what i really had to get out there was
it fully aligns with the study that i'm
looking at right now
dr mchugh points to the reality that
because sex change and i quote
it's physically impossible it frequently
does not provide
the long-term wholeness and happiness
remotely that people seek
unfortunately many professionals now
view health care including mental health
care like rami said
primarily as a means of fulfilling
patient desires rather than treating
pathology whatever those are yeah
so i wanna i wanna pose a question to
you and everybody at home
which is easier to change genetic
biology
or your psychology
you want us to answer that yeah which is
easier to change
your genetic biology or your biology
genetically
or english includes sex and gender and
so on and so forth
or your psychology which is
easier to change
this is pretty obvious psychology
yeah genetically you can't change
yourself if we could genetically modify
ourselves i would have a beard by now
unfortunately we can't do that
if you really think about it what he
said um even if i don't want to change
my psychology
it changes itself sometimes mental state
moves emotions
rather biology you can't leave it alone
and let it change itself unless it's
like
puberty or something like that but yeah
you're right subhan allah
while we're on this topic i want to
mention that i came across this tick
tock video and it was
this of this young man who was uh
debating with a conservative online and
the conservative was a
hard-headed individual right this person
brought sources and arguments and this
person just said
gender is not a flavor of ice cream you
can't choose which one you want so on
and so forth and even though i do agree
with them
he wasn't addressing the point and the
point he brought up was
one and this is something that i want to
get out of the way if anyone thinks this
is an argument i want to get out of the
way
when it comes to um there being multiple
genders or transgenderism and so on and
so forth
two arguments he made firstly there are
multiple sexes
five or six that we have found currently
and what he's referring to is the fact
that there is xx which is for a male
correct no female that's for a female x
for a female
okay thank you that's why i asked and
then x y is for ml then correct
there are other versions such as x x x y
which seems to be the most rare
occurrence
with births they range anywhere from one
in every 18 000 births
to one in every 50 000 births that's how
that's how rare it is
so we tried to make this argument and
say that there are so many sexes
therefore there are
different genders but if you actually do
a quick scholarly research look up
scholarly papers
you'll find that x x actually
is a chromosomal um abnormality
abnormality thank you that only occurs
in men
biological males and it affects things
like their
um intellectual
uh scope and may intellectually disable
them in some
sense it may um weaken their muscle tone
it may shorten their wee-wee
it it may uh cause infertility but this
is only in males
so at the end of the day you still have
a male and with other ones you still
have a
female so this is not really an argument
and the second argument he made was one
i found a lot more convincing
but it does not have enough ground to
stand on and what he said was that
transgender people the transsexual
people from a young age
their brain scans line up more with the
gender they prefer than the gender
they're given biologically which poses a
question one which is easier to change
psychology or biology you can't change
biology therefore psychology is the only
one
but people have it the other way around
where they want to change the biology
the objective truth to fit their
subjective psychology which may
fluctuate which may change
but there was a doctor i believe a few
decades ago in the 70s actually
named staller and he actually did uh
research
and he had this theory that he wanted to
propose and
investigate that young men prettier men
young boys who are seen as more
attractive cute boys
are are you born
on mine yeah you pointed a black space
over here
on my screen you just pointed to nothing
yeah
but fair so he hypothesized that more
attractive young men or young boys are
treated more feminine
therefore develop more feminine
psychology
female psychology and men or
uglier looking young girls are treated
more like men and therefore develop more
men like psychology he brought this to
the test and he found this to be true
he found this to be true one year he
investigated with the boys
he found it to be true and in one year
he investigated with the girls i believe
and he
also found it to be true when i say i
believe i don't know if it was in the
same year or
years apart what i remember was a year
or two apart
but god knows best he did these
experiences experiments nonetheless
and we find that in present day
psychology
scholarly articles you can look these
all up yourself if you don't believe me
it's like uh psychologically we're
affected by our surroundings and how we
are treated by others which is why
you'll find a lot of people
a lot of people who have daddy issues a
lot of girls have daddy issues go for
like
messed up men or a lot of homosexual
people actually have a traumatic
upbringing or they were molested as a
kid
or they didn't have a father figure in
their life or
there's some kind of what we would call
a traumatic experience in their
upbringing as a young kid
or even as a teen or a preteen or
sometimes even as an adult in some cases
that affects them psychologically to the
point where they begin to believe
these things about themselves and look
to make this
a an objective reality by changing what
as the article you mentioned by that
university mentioned
is not changeable see bro there's this
wonderful thing that
angel enlightened me with and it was
that all
men are born men do you want to like go
a little deeper into that
for the audience
you want to elaborate a little bit on
that yeah
so he was telling me something how like
all men are born men
but not the same there's varying degrees
and tendencies
of testosterone and masculine energy
right so
go a little bit of that
i don't remember all right let me remind
you bro
you're still born a guy nine out of ten
guys have a gay thought growing up ah
there we go there we go
so see like this
in our heads let's say every single day
we have
more than
just a rough estimate of let's say five
thousand thoughts
just an estimate it's not an exact
number right
let's say you have five thousand
thoughts running in your head
are you in control of those five
thousand thoughts no
you're not in control you're probably in
control maybe like
50 and that's being generous maybe a
hundred
maybe a hundred all right now if you're
in control of so little you
you you control just the tip literally
just a tip and there's all these
thoughts that are
just out of your control now imagine you
have a thought that runs in your hand
that you're gay and does it necessarily
mean you're gay
or is it just a random thought imagine
if someone has a thought in their head
that
they want to end this person's life does
it
actually mean they want to end this
person's life or is it just a random
thought
and that's what you got to ask yourself
is like all right
if i'm having thoughts that i'm gay
all right let's say nine out of ten
dudes have this thought
not all of them are going to fall victim
to
that thought in and of itself like that
thought may come and they might just
laugh at it or they might just
completely write it off
and just let it pass and they'll
continue on with their lives they might
get it again here and there
but they'll continue on with their lives
right but then you have that one dude
who okay now he has this thought coming
in his head where
instead of him being able to laugh it
off into instead of him being able to
write it off
he starts asking himself yo i just
thought about this
am i actually gay and then that's where
it becomes a dis
ease because now before he was at ease
he didn't have any problem now this
thought this random thought ran across
his head
and he's thinking to himself am i gay
because i had this thought
and if he continues to think about that
he begins to obsess
over this one thought and when you
obsess over something
that's what begins to develop even more
and more and more
the more attention you give to it the
more it's going to develop so imagine
this dude is all he's thinking about is
am i gay
am i gay and he can't get this out of
his head and now bro a year later
he's under the full impression that he's
he's gay because he has these thoughts
running in his head
and he's over here looking at dudes like
oh man i can't believe i
i can't believe i'm gay i can't even
have a friendship
with this dude over here because i have
these conflicting thoughts running
inside my head
when it's like that's what a dis-ease is
man it's like
it all started in the mind it was
psychological
but because he fell victim to that
thought
that's what began to develop it's
it makes no difference whether it's a
thought of
homosexuality whether it's a thought of
ending your own life ending a life of
another person a thought of anxiety a
thought of depression
it literally doesn't matter what thought
is planted in your mind at that moment
if you fall victim to it like that's
what's going to
uh feel like a better words develop
you say develop though but like you have
any like experience with that like in
real life
do you know anyone gay you because i
don't know i'm just speaking from on
behalf of me i don't know anyone
like directly that i was super close
with a new on a frequent basis
but yeah so
i had when i was doing personal training
i'll keep names aside i don't i don't
want to like
put anyone on the spot here but i was
doing personal training i had a client
who he was gay
literally he was gay there was no
question to me like you could see him
from miles away and you'd be like oh
yeah this dude's gay
he was a big gay over here and he was
cool with that he was real he was real
he was real happy with it and like you
know as i'm training him i try to like i
try to give him the benefit of that i
try to like still
see him in no different way
i still try to like just be real and be
genuine with him
which i mean that's that's how you
should be with everyone but
this dude i remember i started asking
him why he was gay
you know like not joking around i wasn't
trying to be like
uh pasta sempa you know like and i know
he's not joking around i know he's
probably real real
legit about that now let me get back to
you all right so i'm asking him why is
he gay
and he he told me that he had a
traumatic experience
when he was a kid where he actually got
raped or not raped but
um sexually
molecularly abused yeah sexually
molested by
i want to say it was his cousin or his
uncle or some
male that was in his family that he
trusted at a young age
all right that he trusted so his first
sexual experience
was with the man and it was with someone
who was close to him that he trusted
so he's all kinds of messed up i and
then
when he told me that i remember i went
home and i started researching this and
i was like
do most gay people have a traumatic
childhood experience and you know from
what i got yes
most tend to actually have that you
research it yourself
um i'm not gonna claim that to be 100
the truth but
in this example that i'm giving to you
guys like it is the truth
in this example because for him he
obviously had an issue
and look what happened to him and then
when i started asking him even more
questions
he actually ended up telling me that he
still
got aroused by a woman
but that he just gets more aroused by a
man
which when i s when i heard that i was
like
dude you're not gay
i literally told him i was like you are
not gay and then he like looked at me
but he was shook he like looked at me i
was like
bro listen you are not gay because you
are still aroused by a woman you can't
say
you're bisexual i do not believe that
someone is bisexual someone's bisexual
they're just trying to make an excuse
for being gay but look if you're being
aroused by a woman
and you're saying you you're more
aroused by a man right now that's
because of what you went through as a
kid
it's it's like someone and i don't want
to get too
deep into detail here but it's like
someone getting into
explicit adult content
on the internet you guys know what i'm
talking about the the sexual stuff
i don't need to go in detail with the
naming
but when someone gets into this stuff
they start off
let's say on like something normal and
then that
progresses into something pretty nasty
pretty nasty i like i'm not like i said
i'm not gonna get in detail but my first
things that i used to watch were pretty
disgusting and
for a while that's the only thing that
aroused me
but it's like once i stopped watching
this stuff that no longer aroused me and
then it was the normal things that
aroused me like
a normal woman like a normal interaction
with a woman
you know just talking and having a
conversation like that
that made me feel some type of way right
and what i'm trying to say here
is that what happened to this dude in
his childhood
caused him to basically have this
almost this like set thing where it's
like ah this is what's arousing me but
it's like
if he could only either one get
help externally from someone close to
him like family or
psychological you know a psychologist or
two dude look within man like
meditate and pray like spend time with
yourself and like really
just get down to these root issues
and really ask yourself the question why
are you gay
and like you you'll probably hear
yourself and that's what i'm trying to
say is that like
the dude ended up telling me all this
stuff and um
just crazy dude you're amazing i commend
you for not
you know leaving his names out leaving
his identity and all that
but it was an excellent story man at the
end of the day i get it
you have a kid who's five six seven
like breaks my heart that they're even
younger sometimes
but they're out here with someone like
brother angel said someone they trust an
older cousin
uncle sometimes even their grandfather
who knows
and they're out here having their first
event that gets them the most
physically aroused being a guy
just like angel said he still in his
later life
felt aroused from a girl but it was
never the same he's out here chasing
that first high
you will never get that first high
that's why people get psychologically
addicted to weed
all they're trying to do from a freudian
perspective is they're trying to
recreate that first high
bad news guys you will never get that
first time you think you will
and that's why you fall into an
addiction but anyway that's not that you
know there
the point that angel was trying to say
leads into my next discovery from my
research
which is kind of crazy the overwhelming
majority
of child molestation is homosexual
what that means is if you have two
groups you got one group of
heterosexuals one group of homosexuals
the probability that the second group of
homosexuals would have
a child molester in that group is
astronomically higher than the
probability that there would be one
in the heterosexual group this largely
like my bro said stems from childhood
abuse and trauma the first most intense
aroused
experience a guy handles if it's from a
guy you got kind of raped
not kind of let's not let's not beat
around the bush it was sexual abuse it
was childhood
misconduct and molestation they pretty
much got off to that
psychologically if not physically and
now they're trained
psychosocially to only crave that
thinking they're gay thinking that's
what's what's going to get them up
i also agree guys not to like talk more
about the videos that anno was talking
about
um you know alhamdulillah i'm pretty
sure we all broke free from that
but i remember like when i used to
partake in that and watching it it was
it was crazy like there was a lot of
times i feel like it does have a lot to
do
with homosexuality there'd be there are
different angles you guys know what i'm
talking about they would zoom in
to the guy i'm like yo why are they
showing this i'm not trying to see this
like i didn't come here for this and
then zooming into things that i'm not
trying to see and it's like
you might not think about it you know
like as
literally as okay cool i'm slowly
becoming gay
but it is kind of conditioning you and
at the very least desensitizing you
to being okay seeing that things that
weren't there before
this whole multi-trillion dollar
industry
isn't that sad but yo and let me
let me piggyback off that for a second
i'll pass it right back
but um it's not just sexual molestation
you know that's something from my own
research and from my own
uh insight you know meditating and
praying on it but
it's from any traumatic experience in
childhood
so like me being abusing my childhood
like
there could have been a huge probability
that i could have gone down that path
but you know alhamdulillah
just becomes the abuser um are you
talking about
abused becomes the abuser type scenario
yes
but that's not what i'm talking about
that's that's also true but i'm talking
about
homosexuality okay i'm talking about
that it's not just
a traumatic sexual experience in your
childhood because there's there's
probably some people that might be
watching it
who might be saying ah but i've never
had a
sexual traumatic experience in my
childhood and i'm gay
like i said it's not just sexually
traumatic experiences
any traumatic experience that's like
it's just too much for you to process as
a little kid
it's too much for you to process so what
you end up doing as a little kid is you
you throw it into the back the recesses
of your mind to where it's like
you just you're trying to get away from
it you you're doing everything possible
to get away from it which
let's be honest that's that's what we do
as kids we couldn't really deal with um
anything that was too too big too
demanding too
traumatic you know at least that's what
i can say from experience when i was
being abused as a kid
but it's like i'm saying that i went
through that as a kid
and there was a huge probability that i
could have gone down that path
of developing homosexuality or whatever
other
mental i'm not going to say disorder
because we already talked about this but
of the mind this is this is of the mind
but alhamdulillah
sharing that with us but yeah i don't
think i got to say no further i think he
perfectly reiterated my point
next thing i want to talk about probably
not going to take more than 10 seconds
hiv
and aids transmission is abnormally
higher guys
in the world in nature in different
populations
in countries in continents just because
of
homosexuality and this agenda that
they're pushing forward
rami you got some stats on getting
checkups and
i don't know about that so
yeah so the cdc centers for disease
control and prevention i actually have a
few
articles and very easy read ups on this
so on average i'll say different sites
may report different things but
generally it's all the same
so i find that this website is a bit
easy going
easy going when it comes to the way they
word things
like the way they word this point where
they say and i quote
against the cdc sexually active and
sexually active gay and
bisexual men may benefit from more
frequent hiv testing
and they put example every three to six
months and this is actually something
you find consistently on most of the
medical
websites out there when they talk about
homosexuals
or sexually active homosexuals getting
tested for hiv and other stds and such
and most of them are encouraged
to get tested every three to six months
where as the next point
it says anyone who has unsafe sex or
shares injection uh drug equipment
and we're talking about sharing drug
equipment
right like a needle or something they're
only required to get tested
once a year on average they have other
statistics
like uh all adults and adolescents from
13 to 64 should be tested at least once
a year
certain people should be tested at least
once is all they say
at least once for hiv um so on
actually they don't even say this is
this is the point where they say 13 to
64 year olds
should be tested at least once for hiv
they don't even say once a year
they just say at least once and
sexually active homosexual people are
required to get it done more frequently
and now this is because obviously they
have a higher risk of contracting
something
and this is not just limited to
homosexual it is amplified with
homosexual intercourse but it's actually
with anal intercourse as well
as a whole which is why allah also
prohibits
anal intercourse even if it's a man to a
woman
rather than a man to a man because that
is haram
i forget the wording allah used in the
quran but he makes it known that it is
it is it is very bad it's haram so
even looking at it from that perspective
if two homosexuals have intercourse
and there's for lack a better word to
use
clear uh wording they there's anal
penetration
they're more likely to contract an std
through those means
they're more likely than any promiscuous
person
who has multiple partners i'll just put
it like this a homosexual man who has
multiple partners
of course homosexual men must get
checked
more frequently than a heterosexual man
who has
multiple multiple partners
and this is again like i said because
they're at greater risk so we see that
there is a
a uh infectious risk and a risk of
actual diseases
sexually transmitted diseases when it
comes to
homosexuality as a practice as a
practice nothing psychological but as a
practice
um if you want any if you have anything
to say on this comment
um but i wanted to mention something
about the last point quickly
so am i free to do so
so this is not just with homosexuality
becoming
more normalized and uh more open for
people to see even people of a very
young age for some reason they're
teaching very young children
sex ed where i actually have a friend
who told me that learning about sex ed
messed them up as a young kid they were
not ready and messed them up
and this is unfortunately the experience
of many young kids who don't know
anything about even being straight or
homosexuality or anything like that
they don't know anything about sex
they're young kids they don't have any
puberty they shouldn't know about this
stuff but they're taught it in school
nonetheless
and this could effectively mess them up
as well which is an issue
and if you look just generally at
promiscuity
in the west you could see that decades
ago on tv and television
it wasn't really promiscuous you didn't
see much and then later on they came out
with
pornography in like cinemas or a more
cinematic setting and magazines
and playboy mansion and all this
provocative stuff and then it made its
way onto television
and as it made its way onto television
it made its way into the hearts and the
minds of people
who became more promiscuous and that's
why we normalized today
we normalized things like cheating back
before i was practicing i had a girl ask
me
if she can just for one day just for a
night hook up with somebody else
at a rave she doesn't even know who it's
gonna be just to have fun
and like when when was this normal when
did this become a normal thing
and it's because it propagated so much
on media and in society
it's become normal and we see i'm just
about to end
just about the end and we see with
homosexuality they're also putting this
into the media and it's open for
everybody men children
well men women and children to see
i was going to add that it's also in
those videos that we were talking about
the whole industry
there's a lot of weird topics man
cheating incest
i don't know man like makes me feel some
type of way but anyway
guys i just want to reiterate quickly
the points that we have
and just know we're not we're not out
here like being some like scholars like
but i'm just going to speak for myself
like i'm a grad student
studying like osteopathic medicine i've
done my undergrad i'm 20 i'm
over 22. so like i'm out here like i
really like science
i don't you know i don't believe in
things that have no basis
so trust me when i tell you that when
i'm looking at all these
these studies i have here like kind of
like what angel was bringing up i got
studies for everything
does maltreatment in childhood affect
sexual orientation in adulthood
uh prevalence of childhood sexual abuse
among lgbt mental analysis
disparities in childhood abuse
victimization in physical
and sexual abuse like he said in
heterosexual
versus lesbians and bisexuals this
there's too much but
it's not something that we're just
pulling out of thin air
and i hope you guys understand all the
points that we brought so far
if you guys do have anything to say
about that please reach out to us
definitely
we're we're looking to let's just spread
truth
spread scientific i guess foundation not
something that we just feel
should be or shouldn't be uh but yeah to
reiterate the points
the the dsm completely removed by the
apa's
nomenclature tax force homosexuality and
transgenderism from sexual deviance
purely due to protests you can find this
anywhere you look
not due to scientific advancement or
medic medicinal or medical
uh i guess revolution right they then
created these terms like partner
homophobia which homophobia doesn't make
sense because
it's a more of a political statement
than a phobia which doesn't do a medical
disorder justice they talked about
gender identity and pronouns which we
could talk about later
um then we we talked about uh how
modern medicine today or at least the
lgbtq community
is telling us to go to the doctor and
share our thoughts and emotions and
create a diagnosis ourselves
rather than giving them the symptoms
which is medically sung
and let them deem the diagnosis
we then talked about how suicide rates
post-op are astronomically higher than
pre-op guys
why would we suggest a movement that has
a suicide rate
20 times higher post-op than pre-op like
this is insane
i'm just reading some of the stuff right
now the overall mortality
for sex reassigned persons was higher by
20 fold than controls sex reassigned
persons also had an increased risk for
suicide attempts
and psychiatric inpatient care so it's
not just suicide it's just debt
from all of the causes period
psychiatric inpatient care
comparisons with control matched on
reassigned sex
yield for higher anxiety and for higher
mental disease right we then talked
about hiv
and aids transmission um and
tying it back into islam guys
homosexuality
which by definition is just a feeling an
inclination towards being attracted to
the same sex
right just like ono said we all had that
thought nine out of ten guys had that
thought at least once in their lifetime
it's a feeling it's an emotion allah
does not i guess condemn us for thoughts
and emotions
we don't get sins for these thoughts
right so
let's get that clear islam doesn't say
okay it's bad to have thoughts it's bad
to do this
you know this whole homosexuality thing
take that out it's the act
that we're talking about right because
the act is now
legitimizing a pathology by definition
of what we talked about so far
that you had up here it's legitimizing
and taking action
on something that was transient which is
an emotion which is kind of
doesn't make sense to me it's like do we
not have thoughts of
committing murder maybe right don't
don't take words out of my mouth guys
but
are we gonna go commit these acts how
does that make us any different than
animals you might say oh animals have
you know
homosexuality occurs naturally in nature
yeah so does infanticide
and genocide and murder where do you
draw the line
there's this thing called trans age
coming out of guys and girls it's
basically saying you can identify as a
different
age because you feel like you are that
age what does that mean
there's this guy who's who's a child
molester a pedophile
he he said the same thing as the lgbtq
people that i was born this way
he was 60 he molested a 10 year old
and he said he identified as an 11 year
old during that
i believe he was 11 or 9 which makes no
sense
and what's next people are going to try
to identify as different species
i don't know man like it makes me feel
some type of way that
as a society in hindsight this whole
movement tells you
yeah we want equality yeah we're trying
to be progressive
but it makes me think that it's kind of
regressive i don't know if you want to
elaborate on that a bit
no
come on man i mean i'm i'm ready to play
devil's advocate but
i feel like romney has something to add
on that all right
let's go for it then but yeah guys
i feel like i feel like we've done more
than enough of a solid scientific
foundation and you're ready to you're
ready for me to ask you a question bro
why are you gay
why are you gay no but real talk
i might have played devil's advocate
with y'all okay so
big question that
it's um out is um
why are gay people treated the way
they're treated in
islamic countries why are they stoned to
death why are they
uh treated like trash
you know if if islam is such a peaceful
religion why is it that
homosexual dudes homosexual women are
being stoned to death
okay i got an answer but i look up to
rami
in a lot of different affairs and
different i guess more
you know things that people are unsure
of i look at him forgotten sometimes so
i want him to go for it first and i'm
gonna i'm gonna see you for the lines
with my answer
all right inshaallah if there's anything
i miss feel free to jump in either of
you
so the issue is people
correspond muslim countries with islam
and islamic law but there's an issue
with this islamic law
is just islamic law you don't have
different versions of it it's just
islamic law
but there are different countries which
all have different rulings
so who's right which one fully
represents islam
and the truth of the matter is none of
them fully represents them not even
saudi arabia which everybody loves to
pull out well saudi arabia does not
women drive therefore islam oppresses
women
this is a false deductive argument
because it operates under the assumption
that saudi arabia
perfectly follows islam but if you look
at the most basic
idea of islam or the basic one of the
more basic laws of sharia
in islam which is means islamic law
is that there should be one muslim
nation
with one ruler but what do we have we
have
king abdullah king muhammad king this
king that
this leader that leader this president
and that president for
muslim lands all throughout the globe
predominantly in the middle east now
this is an issue because this directly
goes against islam so what else
are they missing when it comes to islam
so we look back to where it started
and it actually started with the fall of
the ottoman empire
they were in a very weak state and it
was during world war one they got
involved
they lost and ottoman there was no such
thing as saudi arabia lebanon severe
iraq back then it was just
all of it was ottoman empire ruled by
them they fell
and people literally drew the map of the
middle east and said this is
jordan this is syria this is lebanon
and it's just a clear case of dividing
and conquering now with this divide and
conquer
in this this movement from the west the
strategy from the west
they also colonize these places as you
have us
embassies and even israel embassies in
places
in the middle east they have colonized
these lands and
implemented their views and their moral
standings
predominantly judeo-christian views onto
the middle east
and now judeo-christian views we see
had things in the past like slavery like
murdering apostates murdering people who
don't really
agree with your religious views
the predominant ones you have things
like murdering homosexual people
burning people you suspect to be uh
witches i wouldn't say that's
necessarily judeo-christian
but it was more of the
previous like hundreds of years back
kind of uh
view if there was a witch burn her alive
so on and so forth
and if you look at the history
of when the ottoman empires did
something like uh
enacted punitive laws death penalties
there's actually
transcribes of the uh some of
their their writings and their findings
and so on and so forth and you if you
read it
you'll actually find that they were a
lot more reluctant they didn't want to
do these punishments but it was the law
therefore they did it
but if you look at the west they seemed
a bit overly excited to do these things
because it happened so often
where somebody would be murdered for
this that or the other so it was a
western view that was actually
implemented onto
islamic countries islamic countries
majority
muslim countries but if you look
throughout the quran and the sunnah
you will find little to no basis unless
you take one narration
or one story like the story of luke
alaihi islam in the quran
completely out of context without
all the other hadith and the scholarly
opinions and the writings of the most
original scholars of islam and people
who are deemed to be the giants of islam
real quick though yeah just for people
that aren't too familiar with the story
of new delhi do you want to just give
the quickest quick notes that you can
click notes okay so i'll i'll start with
devil's advocate what they say is
the people of lot which is the english
version the people of lot were
gay and god destroyed them therefore
religion is intolerant towards gay
people and believes they should be
destroyed
but if you look in surah saad in the
quran
what does allah say allah lists a bunch
of nations and i believe
coleman lut was the people of lot were
one of them i believe
and he says all of these people took
their messengers as a liar and
disbelieved in the messengers
so my punishment was justified so allah
is saying he punishes
nations for what disbelieving in the
messenger and their message which is to
believe in god
that's why god punishes these people he
doesn't say in the quran they were gay
and that's the only reason we punish
them
homosexuality the activist is a sin and
they engage in that but there are
narrations of them being
i think robbers and thieves and
murderers
and even biblical stories mention a
practice of sodomy
and practices of putting a baby
in a statue's arms and and making
basically killing the baby and letting
it cry and banging drums
this is something my friend seth told me
who's studying christianity now
and banging drums to drown out the sound
of the crying baby
so these were not amazing kind innocent
people who just wanted to be gay these
are actually
very violent thieves murderers people
who practice um
killing babies if that was a practice
and
um and the biggest gravest sin was
actually disbelieving in god
and that's why they were punished more
specifically
yeah man like nowhere we you know we're
not saying all gay people are this all
gay people
that we are saying is you're doing
something relying on emotions
it clouds your judgment so much so as
some of these people
who are child molesters would destroy
and let's not be let's be blunt now
dehumanized
an innocent victim child these aren't
people that you want to rely on for
moral backbone
so it's not surprising that they had all
these other issues that you speak of bro
it breaks my heart it truly does but
we do want to let you guys know that we
love the lgbtq
community in the sense that we do have
love for them as human beings
maybe even i it might sound like a reach
to something y'all but
i got love for them more than the these
people running the system
of the lgbtq movement because i'm trying
to help them i'm trying to restore
happiness and balance in their lives
the natural state not do something
that's leading to more suicides more
kids being
messed up and i feel like we got to draw
the line somewhere so
if not now then when if not ask the who
right yeah that's a very good question
and what was anna's question again that
he asked you
the first question he asked was about um
like why are these muslim countries
treating these
uh gay people like that so just to
summarize it it's actually not islamic
views
these may be muslim-majority countries
but they don't get it from islamic views
and actually
a lot of these countries falter in a lot
of places including saudi arabia
because you will not find much bearing
in the quran
and the hadith which are the authentic
sources in
religious text holy scripture of islam
i agree man all right so would you
would you guys say that if someone
is gay someone is
trans if someone is
whatever the hell they are all right
lgbt
iq not trying to disrespect it but why
you guys have so much letters beyond me
if someone is one of these things
is that or is it not their jihad and if
it is a jihad why don't you go ahead and
elaborate on that for
people viewing because i'm pretty sure
that a lot of people are gonna think
jihad is uh these extremists that are
going about doing all these crazy things
if you know what i mean
so rami taught me i guess linguistically
what jihad even means
so why don't you start from there bro so
jihad actually means just a struggle
and jihad sabil is a struggle for the
sake of allah
now a lot of people apply this to as an
hell said jihadists which are islamic
extremists which are
predominantly not great people because
they commit acts of terrorism and so on
and so forth so when we say jihad people
think
this means holy war it does not mean a
holy war it does not mean
war and at all actually it just means a
struggle so
we pray very early in the morning before
the sun even comes up
so this is salaat fazer and it's
nowadays
uh where me and fi live it's around uh
six o'clock i believe
and the sun comes up around 7 30. yeah
so
we have to wake up early and it's a
struggle sometimes and that is jihad
because we're struggling for the sake of
allah
that's jihad so if me as a straight man
is attracted to a woman but i hold
myself back
because i don't want to fall into sin
it's a struggle that is jihad
allah this that is struggling for the
sake of god and that's rewardable
so now if you have a person who has
homosexual inclinations and they do the
same
they hold back even though it is a
struggle that's struggling for the sake
of allah and this person will be greatly
rewarded
a lot of people muslims unfortunately
have this presupposition that if you
feel gay you are
basically going to hell and that's the
end of it but there's an issue with this
because
feeling gay is something that people
can't necessarily control
and there's multiple narrations of the
prophet peace and blessings be upon him
where he said that
allah will not punish a person for
whatever evil thought comes to their
mind evil meaning it's immoral in terms
of islamic objective morality
so if allah doesn't punish a person or
give them a sin for thinking evil
feeling evil then they haven't done any
evil
the evil the immoral act so to speak
actually comes from the action itself
followed by an intention to do or coming
from the intention to do that action
so a person whether whether they are
straight or homosexual
does not get a sin until they actually
act on their desires
and if they hold back just to bring it
back to the point if they hold back that
is them
struggling for the sake of allah which
is jihad i love i love islam and
from the bottom of my heart for that
alone that if you have a thought
of stealing for example and then you end
up not spewing
you get more good deeds than the person
that didn't even have the thought of
steering to begin with
yeah it's about a lot of things yeah i
like that but
to bring it to bring about guys like
this message i understand anna's
question
completely like it is a stigma and this
i'm assuming all right just like i might
be called out for assuming people's
genders today
i'm also assuming most of our viewers
are straight heterosexual
call me whatever but basically muslim as
well
not go ahead yeah based on that
assumption guys and girls
you guys are straight more times than
not like most of our viewers so
you're probably wondering why are we
telling you this wouldn't it be useful
to have
a gay guy or someone of the lgbtqi
whatever he said
alphabet community wouldn't it be more
beneficial wouldn't it be something
not to like to mean anything but
wouldn't they be more resourceful
and valuable not because why would it
why would we doesn't it start with
us shouldn't we lead by example like
how many people do you think are growing
up in the muslim youth community
and they might have these thoughts that
unheld clearly through anecdotal
evidence and through his client as a pt
mentioned
that they might have these thoughts
growing up like why are we out here
like ostracizing them in society as a
muslim guy
as a as i can relate a lot of muslim
youth today might have these weird
thoughts taboo thoughts
and they might what are they going to do
go to the measure and talk to the imam
who's just probably going to call them
out and air their sins oh man like this
is not the way
like and before that let me let me draw
a simple analogy
so it really drives and attaches the
point to the inside of your skulls
we have this pandemic right now cover
19. are we going to go to the people
that already have the virus
and be like guys let's like and then we
do our dawah and then
tell them okay this is how you stay safe
oh man they already got it what are we
doing today
we're not wearing masks okay to save the
people
that already have kova 19 right we're
wearing masks
and we're doing all these things clean
wash your hands disinfect
use alcohol wipes uh you know don't
give everyone a tongue bath outside why
are we doing these things
because we want to stop preventing
and we want to stop and prevent the
spread of cocaine to the people that are
already healthy
the people the mass majority of the
population 99 whatever percent
that hasn't gone covered we want to help
keep them straight
right so we don't want them getting
covered so what we're going to do
is target them as the main i guess
group demographic to help tackle this
this issue
i'm not comparing cova 19 to um
to homosexuality but what i am doing is
explaining why it's beneficial to not
always go to the people
that you kind of want to give the truth
to
because you do it more through leading
by example oftentimes
than just going directly head on because
even though we might not
go ahead on we might not attack people a
lot of people i've seen from my
experience
in that community take everything very
personally take everything like
like not like a grain of salt like
you're attacking their nature you're
cursing them
and they get very hurt about it and
we're just trying to have a discussion
yo and to add on to that
if it is indeed a jihad
that jihad and it's something that they
have to struggle
and they have to get past
would it them be something that they're
going to be
fighting for the rest of their life
i mean that is a case-to-case basis i've
actually heard believe it or not
i've actually heard of of cases where
imams um
talk about well the imams talk about
cases where they have people who come
and they say they're gay and then
eventually through whatever process they
take i don't know the details of it
they're actually they're no longer gay
so in some cases you will have that and
in some cases you may not have that
but allah knows best yeah bro but isn't
there a gay gene
i'm playing double zag dude um
actually no there's no such thing as far
as we know there's no such thing as
the engaging so just quickly i want to i
want to mention uh because you mentioned
the dsm
and the apa there's an article titled
a scholarly article titled homosexuality
and scientific evidence
on suspect anecdotes antiquity data
and broad generalizations by robert l
kinney
iii and he basically talks about how
the apa's evidence upon critiquing it
actually does not
result in their conclusion which is that
homosexuality is not
a disorder and therefore should be
removed from the dsm
so i encourage people to take a quick
look at this it's fairly long so
read whatever you want from it take
whatever you want from it um
but he provides reasons as to why
um their evidence is not sufficient
enough basically
so bismillah
when it comes to a trait traits or
characteristics of a human being
as far as i know there's only two forms
there are genetic traits characteristics
and there are psychological traits or
characteristics
i ask all anybody else if there are any
other types
other than genetic slash biological or
psychological
let me know what they would be i
personally can't think of any i've not
heard of anyone
i've not heard of any other one just to
reiterate your point bro you're right
100
there's only three determinate
determining factors to
any expression of any trait there's
going to be genetic
environmental or the third one
epigenetic which is the interaction
of the genetic environment
take it away go in thank you so for the
sake of making it easy to understand
because even environmental
would manifest psychologically in your
head
which is teaching you to act that way so
that's why i just generalize it with
genetically or psychological because
your psychology is influenced i think i
mentioned this earlier
uh by your surroundings as well in the
way you're treated by society your
parents your family so on and so forth
so it's either genetic or psychological
there is no such thing
as a gay gene as far as we know
therefore it must be psychological
now just because it's a psychological
abnormality
does this mean that it's a it's a
disorder
actually no by the apa uh the api's
definition
because if you were to classify anything
that's irregular psychologically as a
disorder you would have to
call people who are exceedingly smart
um you would have to consider them
people who suffer from disorders people
who are
exceedingly talented you would have to
call them people who suffer from
disorders but we wouldn't deem these
people
as people who suffer from disorders so
the way the apa themselves described it
is something basically and i'm
rephrasing it
basically what it what they say is that
something that hinders a person's life
something that causes harm in a way
physical or emotional harm to themselves
or to others
and what we discussed right actually
named uh a few reasons like um
suicide rates uh post-op uh depression
anxiety
uh mental illness rates uh we talked
about the
std rates of homosexual people more
sexually active yes thank you any is
there are there any more
that i missed more than that that's
that's more or less it
okay yeah and this amongst perhaps other
reasons we haven't come across we don't
even we didn't even mention in this
podcast
because this podcast has been fairly
short for a large topic like this
so from this we can derive with this
evidence
that perhaps it actually is what
the apa defines as a psychological or
mental
disorder because it actually negatively
impacts people's lives for these reasons
which were
taken from scholarly articles or
academic articles
uh as well so if it's not genetic it's
psychological if it's psychological
and and hinders a person's life harms a
person's life or other people's lives
it is a disorder
is it impossible or illogical or
homophobic or
unfounded to say that homosexuality
might actually be a disorder not to put
any disgrace to these people
we love everybody for the sake of allah
but
is it is it completely
uncomprehendable is it completely
unfounded no it's not
it's not what we've discussed if
anything
if anything i would challenge people to
bring reasons why it's actually
acceptable
because the apa the apa
actually according to robert l kennedy
iii
did not have enough sufficient evidence
and as if i had mentioned were more
likely and i think he wrote an article
about this as well or somebody else did
i don't have it currently but there are
articles talking about reasons
they may have actually um other than
traditional evidence these reasons they
may have actually removed it from the
dsm
and again we're talking about the
american psychiatric association
i want to take a quick minute to remind
everybody about cognitive dissonance
if you are frustrated right now we are
not attacking anybody
be and let be live and let live right
we're not attacking anybody
we're just taking a more academic
approach to the subject
and quoting sources scientific and
academic sources
by professionals in regards to all these
matters we've talked about
for the most part and we're basically
showing
another way of viewing it and now is
that incorrect
because a few decades ago almost lgbtq
basically
they were trying to push this idea of
viewing homo
homosexuality in a different light they
pushed a different view of homosexuality
so if i'm doing the same why should i be
condemned
and not them well not me but
us so we're just painting it in a
different light in light of evidences
and in light of these academic papers
if you are experiencing cognitive
dissonance you're feeling angry
frustrated
it's because you have two ideas in your
head what you've been taught what you
believe
and what we've presented to you you
can't you don't want to get rid of what
you believe nobody wants to we're all
comfortable we're all idle
we don't want to get rid of our bubble
but you can't exactly
logically irrationally just dismiss
everything we've talked about
so it sits in your mind and they battle
with each other
causing you to feel anxious and angry
and frustrated and you take
this out on us but the real way to deal
with this would be to sit
and reflect by yourself which has been
shown to be very very helpful
self-reflection and just think about
what we've talked about do your own
research ponder reflect
and think about it especially the
deductive argument we presented at the
end
not genetic psychological psychological
hinderance therefore disorder
and see if there's any way to comprehend
this or to
uh what's the word i'm looking for
reconcile this
with your political views on
homosexuality
so with that being said we love all
people for the sake of god
i'm going to pass it on to fight on if
they have any
more remarks on this yeah dude so
playing devil's advocate again here and
this is speaking very speculative
you said that it's not a disorder
because if someone's let's say extremely
smart
or extremely talented that wouldn't be a
disorder
because it's um it's not disrupting
their life
but i mean bro prime example elon musk
this guy
is just on another level when it comes
to his state of mind and like what he
does he's very obsessive
over what he he's doing and he even had
a podcast with joe rogan and just from
watching this podcast from a very
speculative point of view
you can tell that this guy's
he's he's kind of missing something or
he's not fully
content not fully happy so it's like
yeah
he's a mastermind yeah he is doing some
amazing things like he could be
uh the one percent of the human
population who is um
ahead like almost albert einstein or
nikola tesla
was like okay they're they are advanced
so it's like
what i'm trying to say is they may be
where they are because of obsession
because
of uh having let's say ocd
obsessive-compulsive disorder that in
and of itself
is a known disorder so if that is known
as a disorder if
speculatively speaking someone who is
brilliant in this way is this way
because
of something and you know there's a give
and take with everything
you went somewhere you lose somewhere
else
so with that being said would that not
then
make homosexuality a disorder
um if it does as i think we've done a
pretty
good job of showing it does um
negatively impact people's lives as
individuals who are homosexual and even
people who aren't in the form
of eventually it leads to or could lead
to which it has
led to um pedophilic uh actions and
molestation and so on and so forth
unfortunately
may god punish all the abusive and
oppressive people
the molesters of pedophiles and those
who are vile in that nature
so what are you talking about perhaps
could be
more of a workaholic or somebody who
is uh almost obsessive over their works
so i wouldn't classify someone who is
intellectual
as suffering from a mental disorder i'm
not a psychologist by the way
i'm not psychologist i'm put out there
i'm not i don't have the
facilities for that big man i don't have
the facilities
to diagnose anybody but um according to
healthline.com
as you mentioned it leads to ocd adhd
they express symptoms
of psychiatric disorders which are
mentioned in the
the dsm so these people yes
perhaps elon musk i don't know but these
people may actually
exhibit symptoms of mental illnesses
and there are scholarly articles on this
as well
but by the definition by the definition
that the apa provides that it is harmful
to a person
or to people and we have to include end
to people
to others because perhaps the psychopath
is not harmful to himself perhaps the
narcissist is not harmful to himself
but they may be harmful to other people
you would still consider a psychopath
someone who suffers from a mental
illness he might not be
harming himself but he's harming other
people or sociopath or
so on and so forth so
brother rami talked a lot about the the
how pivotal it is to worry about your
psyche
right because we talked about how it's
not genetic so it has to be
psychological
um so what's the big deal guys i'm gonna
play devil's advocate again
you got kids in school you're forcing
them to be princesses and wear pink
dresses
and you've got you got girls do the
opposite it's like
what's wrong with that where's that
going to leave
okay so as we talked about things like
this may lead to
confusing states such as gender
dysphoria
and gender dysphoria may lead to things
like transgenderism
and transgenderism very well may lead to
trans regret
and there are studies and documentations
um on trans regret and people who look
to remove the breasts that they've grown
from conducting um from from having uh
high
shots not shots but high doses of
estrogen and so on and so forth to
increase their feminine side because we
talked about how everybody has a
masculine feminine side ultimately
right and they have this from trans
regret
so you might have that confusing state
and so on and so forth which a person
may not and i think this is the key
point
an individual who does not suffer from a
traumatic experience or is not
taught certain things that confuses them
would not eventually
suffer from gender dysphoria become a
transgender
and try and go undergo trans regret so
i think it comes down to not confusing
children by implementing these views
forcefully
just to accept people adults
adults who have already decided this
for themselves why should you then
confuse
these children that end up making
life-altering decisions at a very young
age
even if it is backed up by a a um
so-called professional because these
professionals look like we mentioned
misdiagnosed people
and efficiently and effectively
unfortunately
ruin lives
i'm being blunt guys like it really does
run pretty deep in school
like they got kids aged 12 13 they're
trying to pass a bill to
let them know that hey you can start
taking these medications called puberty
blockers
if you feel like you're not ready to
become a man for a boy
and a woman for a girl and you want time
to transition and gather your thoughts
and feelings
so you can take these hormones to stop
you from entering puberty
it's like big pharma is going to benefit
obviously because pharmaceutical is
always
one of the culprits but it's like where
do you draw the line
they're trying to pass a bill to waive
parental consent
from kids being able to do this they're
they're forcing kids to alter their
psychology
and coercing them to then change their
biology this is not okay that's why the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
peace be upon him
the man who dresses like a woman and the
woman that dresses like a man
because he knew that changing your
psychology it's only going to lead to
more dis-ease
it's not going to lead to the happiness
and satisfaction that you think
you're gonna have and it's okay to like
there are some girls that grow up more
of a tomboy
there are some guys that grow up a
little more feminine but like rami said
that's their jihad that's their struggle
that's their life everyone is created
different but we're more similar than
we're not but we're not the same
so why should we try to become the same
and just ignore our differences which
make us special and unique
that is very true very true dude
and like you just made me think that if
you have a dude
who let's say he grows up only around
women
like that's that's what he has to to
model
like that's his role model as a kid and
no one can dispute that as a kid you're
always looking up to someone
you always you always have a role model
you're always trying to like
be something more than you are when
you're a little kid
and it's like if you're a little kid and
all you have is females around you
and then let's say you go on to like
start having a lot of female friends
like
guys what do women talk about
women talk about
dudes women talk about
things that are feminine that are of
women and it's like
if a guy is around that too much like
he'll start to adapt that whether he
wants to or not because we are a product
of our environments
and it's like that's just scary man
let's just scare like how many dudes
nowadays
are in that position and have gotten to
that point where it's like well this is
all that they hear this is all that they
see
this is all that they're living this is
all they're experiencing to where it's
like now they're questioning their own
sexuality because
the only thoughts running in the head is
the programming
that was instilled by their environment
and by the people that were around them
the entire time
that's scary dude that's the kind of
luck
let me just throw in something right
there bro um and then i'm gonna let you
go
what's even scarier is what you're
saying bro it's not
ironically bro it's like it's literally
science like they did a study scientific
literature they proved that
i believe 66 or 67 percent of
all gay guys grew up either single mom
right so no daddy daddy wasn't in the
house predominantly
a lot of older sisters no brothers no
male influence
or with no parent at all this is crazy
so
you're growing up around women you're
going to start thinking like women talk
like women
i love my mom and i'm sure you guys do
too but
mama and mama can raise a boy
mama can tell a boy what to do what to
not do be nice do this do that but mama
can't reason then
yeah yeah bro very true and uh
relating this back to the these
experiments and the
observations that uh staller had back in
the 70s
with the young boys and the young girls
being
treated a certain way by society and
affected the way their brain operated
making them more
feminine if they were a boy or more
masculine if they were a girl
just because of the way they were
treated by their outside sources
now i actually asked a psychology
student a graduate
of psychology about this and she
mentioned to me
that people actually exhibit
certain characteristics that they see in
others and they become
a part of them especially if they see
these as good characteristics that we
want to implement
for example women have some very lovely
characteristics our mothers
uh have some very lovely characteristics
like being gentle
kind soft um loving
almost exceedingly helpful where they
would put themselves
they would put everybody else their
children before themselves
and if a young man and generally
speaking this is something that is
traditionally more feminine to be blunt
it is more feminine
that's why moms mothers exhibit it
mostly
so if a young man sees this and he
doesn't have a father
he's going to look to the mom as only
role model and he's going to idolize
these characteristics he's going to
exhibit these characteristics
and overall if he takes that path
it's going to psychologically seem
normal to him
and then he will continue down that path
because it is normal it is politically
correct
and apparently scientifically correct
which we've
i think again done a pretty good job of
showing it is not by any
means you're right man the best partner
cannot become a father and the best
father
cannot be her mother yes
which is why which is probably why
because we can't say
definitely this why allah said this but
which is why
even though divorce is halal it's one of
the most hated things
and when shaitaan will shaytan will ask
a person
or his his shareholding the little
devils the big shaytan will ask the
little devils what did you do
one person will say oh i made a person
do this and that i made a person commit
adultery i made a person uh whatever
and then one sheriff deen one shaitaan
the little one will come and say i made
a household break apart i made a mother
and father or
husband and wife break apart and he will
say come sit beside me
because he has done the best work
because when you disrupt the household
you disrupt the order you effectively
ruin the kids and you're effectively
producing
kids that may come out a little less
developed
or a little hindered to put it lightly
in some way now every person in this
circumstance is not going to come out in
that sense
but as we've discussed with the
statistics predominantly
they are very likely to so this is why
it's probably haram
or not on but it's extremely disliked to
one get married to someone who's not
good for you or not good at all and two
to end up in divorce even though it's
halal because it's necessity it takes
place
it is extremely disliked and shaitan is
the one who loves it which means we
should inevitably
hate it
and guys i'm a reverse so don't shoot me
i'm still new to everything but um
[Music]
if i remember correctly isn't there
hadith or the prophet peace be upon him
said that uh
after 40 days and 40 nights of spending
time with the person like you start to
uh basically take on their traits
am i correct is it something else
perhaps i'm not familiar with the hadith
specifically but the process
did say that loneliness is better than
bad company
and good company is better than
loneliness so he's saying and he says if
anybody acts like a person he's from
amongst them
so he's making two very bold um
uh rules don't be around bad people
if you act like bad people or certain
people you're from those people
if you act like a muslim you're from the
muslims if you act like a christian
you're from you're from the christians
if you act like an atheist or from the
atheist
done so surround yourself with good
people and i believe there are other
hadith but i don't have them off the top
of my head
but um effectively islamically we know
that that is true and scientifically as
well
we know that people exhibit
characteristics of those who are around
them and they become products
of their surroundings and their
environment so that's a very good
truth that's very true and then for
people who are watching
not only do you pick up on good traits
but you actually
pick up on the bad traits even the most
like if if you're hanging around someone
right now let's say you have a friend or
a family member
and they do something that you don't
like you'll probably pick up on that
trade before you pick up on any other
trade because that's the one that you're
paying attention to the most
damn wow yeah
you're right man
all right any final remarks if i had on
head
anything else well i think this is one
of the most
important podcasts that we will ever
make
and if not definitely one of the most
we've made so far
looking forward to many i don't know if
you have anything to say
just why are you gay bro
why are you gay nah nah
the ongoing question in our podcast is
why are you gay fire
bro i'm just gonna be honest guys
i'm gay because i know it's game and
damn
and i kind of want to be like him i'm a
fan boy so
he's gay i'm getting like look at that
he's wearing black that's why i wore
black today guys
i literally changed my [ __ ] today just
to wear the same color as him
he has headphones too let me be honest
with you guys i went outside and bought
these
apple same headphones as him just to
like become like him but i i forgot that
it has like a lightning cable so i can't
really plug it into my mac
so i'm currently not exactly like him
i'm transitioning
right i might take some meds for it but
jessica for everybody who tuned in and
stuck around to the end may allah bless
you all make sure to share the podcast
with those who you think will enjoy it
we appreciate all the deep thinkers out
there because we ourselves
are deep thinkers may allah bless you
all
just want to let you know we are
starting a gofundme very soon
to find angel's
lost beanie that he lost during our trip
today
yo this man is tripping guys
the patreon if you guys like what we're
doing here and you want to support us
make sure to check out our patreon make
sure to check out our socials
i will link them somewhere in the video
once it's posted may allah bless you all
and that being said assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi